Fernand Martin du Mani est une figure
locale d'Amboise ancien carrossier non
non comme on l'appelle ici est devenu au
fil du temps sculpteur il pratique l'art
un peu brut un peu comme lui
des regards qui parlent ceux des
personnages métalliques de Fernand
Martin d'humani 80 ans au compteur et
depuis 20 ans sculpteurs Devrent
singulière à base de pièces détachées de
véhicules
ça c'est mon grand-père badouille
qui a été gazé à Verdun
et c'est le masculin et puis ça c'est
l'aspiration les échappements pour Mick
Jagger qui habite près d'ici au château
de fourchette j'ai mis 4 douzaines de
fourchettes
retour à l'atelier à un jeu de boulon du
château dans le sous-sol de son ancien
garage un capharnaüm d'atmosphère mon
père est arrivé en 29 comme carrossier
je suis né là en 34 et j'y suis encore
dans l'atelier c'était c'était une belle
vie
un enjôleur de l'enjoliveur au grand
cœur Fernand a offert plusieurs de ses
œuvres mais il n'a jamais voulu en
vendre une seule un rien archiste notre
artiste a même décliné la proposition
d'une richissime héritière de la place
Vendôme vous les emmener à New York
voilà pour les exposer elle avait dit il
y a des choses à faire avec je trouvais
que c'était c'était ça servait à rien de
vendre pour une histoire de capitalisme
dans le rétro déjà une quarantaine de
pièces uniques qui mériteraient le coin
de musée promis par la mairie dans ce
maître de la tôle soudée symbolise la
brute par excellence en attendant
Fernand tiens bon le volant et roule
doucement